let's talk about six unexpected signs
of heart disease now since heart disease
pretty much is the number one cause of
death worldwide compared to any other
death i think it's appropriate to
understand this problem a little bit
more especially the unexpected or
surprising signs or symptoms that can
tell you you have a heart problem
without even knowing about it now
regarding heart failure there's two
different situations you have
compensated heart failure and you have
decompensated heart failure now what's
the difference what does that mean
compensated it means that when you have
a weak heart initially
you're not going to have the same output
of
blood flow or oxygen
so the body compensates to help you out
to
increase the amount of blood flow by
increasing the pressure and the
retention of sodium so you cannot also
increase the same amount of fluid
through the body the body is trying to
hold on to the fluid and increase the
pressure and the pulse rate and so
compensated heart failure
has as its symptom
no symptoms except high blood pressure
now why would you have no symptoms well
because you're getting the same output
as a normal heart
but your numbers are just higher so for
a lot of people that have high blood
pressure there really is no symptoms at
least at first and what's really
interesting is that
people then
just take a medication which kind of
camouflages and hides this little
indicator red flag situation you go
about your way thinking well okay good
now i no longer have high blood pressure
so i'm good
but that didn't do anything for the
heart itself in fact it just camouflaged
the real problem
and
then you may start experiencing symptoms
of this medication which really
is experiencing symptoms of the heart
problem now because now we don't have
the output of blood flow so some people
that start medication
that reduce the blood pressure from this
compensation situation start having
edema in the legs they might feel
light-headed fatigued difficulty
breathing okay
those are the the known symptoms
when you have decompensated heart
failure but typically what happens you
have this compensation going on for many
years until the heart gets so weak that
it can no longer compensate and so
that's when you start having the obvious
symptoms of a heart problem and there's
symptoms that people know about and
they're symptoms that people don't know
about like the pitting edema in your
lower ankles if you press into your
lower leg close to your ankle and it
leaves a dent that's pitting edema okay
that what's happening is you're getting
a backup of blood in the body because
the heart cannot push it out it could
also be other things like liver disease
or even adrenal problems but definitely
a heart problem can create that as well
another common symptom of decompensation
would be
you get out of breath very easily
especially when you exercise or go up a
hill another symptom would be pain on
the left arm or chest pain or actually
back up through here but again those are
known symptoms but the ones that people
are not used to hearing about are the
following
excuse me coughing that could be a
version of congestive heart failure
where the blood flow is backing up into
not just your ankles but into organs and
your lungs and creating this irritation
or a cough number three signs of
dementia
you're starting to forget things why
because you don't have the blood flow to
your brain as well as you used to
there's a problem with not getting
enough oxygen and blood flow to the
brain that can affect your memory over
time if it becomes chronic number four
low urine output okay the amount of
urine that you're putting out is
definitely not
what it should be and that is because
your body is retaining
sodium because your body's trying to
compensate for this lack of blood flow
and oxygen so it's just holding on to
fluid all right number five
difficulty breathing when you're laying
flat on the ground okay
so you get relief when you sit up or
stand up a lot of people don't associate
that they think it's always like if i
exercise and i get winded no actually
when you lay on your back and number six
you're awakened out of a sleep one to
two hours later
trying to gasp or trying to catch your
breath that's another sign or a
connection between the heart
and your breathing all right that's all
very interesting but what can we do
about it the first thing is
to
give yourself enough sleep you know they
found in a study that a midday nap can
give you the same benefits as certain
blood pressure medication which is
fascinating so the more sleep you have
the better the heart's going to be in
fact the less sleep you have the more at
risk you're going to be for getting a
heart attack so if you're getting like
five hours or less your risk goes up
considerably and your lifespan decreases
as well unless you're one of those
special individuals that don't need as
much sleep which can happen but it's not
very common all right number two this
relates to a real big
important connection between
refined grains and heart disease when
you consume refined grains in the form
of the breads the pasta the sorrel
not only are you getting the massive
oxidation because it turns in the sugar
and the ear it's kind of like taking
steel wool and rubbing it through your
arteries i mean that's really what it's
equivalent to but also refined grains
are going to pleat your vitamin e
reserve okay and vitamin e is the most
important vitamin
for not just the inside of the arteries
but also the heart muscle itself
when you're low in vitamin e
the heart has to work so much harder in
fact vitamin e is good for all of your
muscles and it's pretty dramatic when
you give people vitamin e and then test
their muscle strength before and after
you'll see a huge change the type of
vitamin e that i would recommend is
tocatrinos that's the best vitamin e for
the heart in fact it works like 50 times
better than the regular tocopherols all
right number three vitamin k2 vitamin k2
is kind of a recently discovered vitamin
it works with vitamin d3 but k2 helps
keep calcium in the right places so it
it helps to keep calcium out of the
arteries it helps to keep calcium in the
bone it also keeps the arteries
from becoming too stiff and guess what
foods are high in vitamin k2
the fats okay the fatty foods and i know
some people watching are going to say
well what about cholesterol this and
that well i have another video for you
to watch in that because that's a whole
different topic there's a massive lie in
that area that you need to know about
all right number four and this is really
really important it's just as important
as sleep is
getting off the high carb diet going on
a low carb diet of course especially
getting off the refined grains if you're
new to my channel i'm going to show you
exactly how to do that i'm going to put
the link down below if you want some
encouragement also go to dr berg.com and
look right at the top there's a button
uh
with success stories and we have over
5000 success stories you can start
reading through these and you're going
to see a lot of people
have
significant improvement with
cardiovascular function
when they start the ketogenic diet now
the next video you need to see is on
cholesterol
very important
i put it right here check it out
you